jouer au tennis avec son recruteur juste
avant son entretien d'embauche un
concept original vécu par ses 30 jeunes
ici de quartiers prioritaires lors du
jeu 7 et job se mardi 6 décembre
organisé pour la première fois attrape
par l'association faites le mur de
Yannick Noah cet événement a permis de
rassembler une dizaine d'entreprises
c'est un concept de Job Dating en fait
directement sur le tennis afin de
désacraliser le recrutement de
déstresser un peu les jeunes ça crée un
lien direct qui est plus facile ou
directement le recruteur et le jeûne se
parle sur le terrain on parlait de
salaire de de comment ça se passe au
niveau du travail
s'il y a des jours de repos à
particulier
je trouve que c'est une méthode très
innovante qui permet aussi de briser la
glace auprès donc de ces candidats
aujourd'hui il faut aller au devant des
candidats il fallait les chercher au
plus près de chez eux donc je pense que
le sport aussi permet de mieux prendre
contact avec eux et puis voilà de
faciliter la communication
après un moment sportif l'ambiance est
devenue plus formelle dans ce cadre
atypique table posée à même le terrain
pour le job dating des postes autour des
métiers de la climatisation de la
mécanique ou encore de l'armée était
proposée pour moi c'est super important
de participer au job dating parce que je
suis à la recherche d'un emploi tu peux
en CDI soit en restauration en commerce
en gardant ça permet aussi de se faire
connaître auprès des jeunes puisque moi
je travaille pour une agence d'intérim
et on se rend compte que les jeunes
connaissent de moins en moins le monde
de l'intérim donc c'est vrai que c'est
important aussi de se faire connaître
quelques barrières en fait des deux
côtés ça lève des barrières peut-être un
peu désappréhensions de la part du jeûne
déjà du gène envers le recruteur c'est
peut-être des fois un monde qui est pas
forcément atteignable mais aussi de la
part du recruteur envers le jeûne qui a
peut-être pas la bonne image des jeunes
de quartier on a mon certain de ces
demandeurs d'emploi étaient formés à la
prise de parole en public à travers des
simulations d'entretien et des
perfectionnement à l'oral présente dans
toute la France l'association faite le
mur intervient chaque année auprès de
13000 bénéficiaires